- C'est comme un cul-de-sac
au quotidien.
- Le manque de ressources dans
le milieu scolaire est criant,
et Myriam Boudreault-Pilon
en sait quelque chose.
Elle enseigne en quatrième année
du primaire, où elle constate
au quotidien que la pénurie
de persoit sentir.
Elle est aussi la mère
de trois garçons qui ont
des besoins particuliers.
MYRIAM BOUDREAULT-PILON,
mère et enseignante
- On manque d'outils, on manque
de temps, on est essoufflés.
Comme parent, je me sens seule
là-dedans, mais comme
enseignante aussi. On se sent
seules là-dedans, même si,
des fois, on a des formations,
mais c'est toujours du surplus
es, du surplus de tâches.
- Elle est en arrêt de travail
parce que les services manquent
pour le plus jeune
de ses enfants.
- C'est un cercle vicieux,
dans le fond, parce que
ceux qui ont des problèmes
ont pas de services.
BIANCA NUGENT, prés., Coal.
parents d'enfants besoins part.
- Le moindrement qu'il y a un
joueur qui manque dans l'équipe,
l'équipe-classe, bien, vraiment,
nos enfasentent
d'autant plus.
- Pour la Coalition des parents
d'enfants à besoins particuliers
du Québec, c'était une
phe annoncée.
Selon la porte-parole,
le gouvernement était au fait
de la pénurie de personnel
depuis des années,mais il a tar.
- Ce qu'on voit,
c'est la pointe de l'iceberg,
mais nous, on vit les vagues
et les chamboulements année
après année. On se demande,
finalement, bien... Elle est où
la volonté politique? Il est où
le leadership politique
pour changer ça?
- Je, Bernard Drainville...
- Nouvellement arrivé en poste,
le ministre de l'Éducation,
Bernard Drainville, se dit
tout à fait conscient
de la pénurie d'enseignants
et de personnel de soutien
qui frappe le réseau.
Il affirme que sa main est
tendue, aux syndicats,
afin qu'ils fassent partie
de la solution.
JOSÉE SCALABRINI, prés., Féd.
des syndicats de l'enseignement
- Si le ministre nous tend
la main, nous, on va être
au rendez-vous, parce que
c'est urgent de revaloriser
la profession enseignante.- Main
est que la situation est encore
loin de s'améliorer.
- L'instabilité qui est vécue
est un défi de plus encore
une fois pour les enseignants.
Il y a des parents qui ont
besoin d'être rassurés,
il y a des élèves qui ont besoin
d'être rassurés.
- Le ministre de l'Éducation
a amorcé une tournée des écoles
primaires et secondaires
de la province pour prendre
le pouls et constater
les enjeux dans le milieu.
Son cabinet affirme que
cette tournée va se poursuivre
dans les prochaines semaines.
Ici Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.